"Lo que estan a punto de escuchar no se ha hecho público antes"
"En otra comunicación radial entre agentes de la Policía Metropolitana,
se puede escuchar a un agente declarar que hay un motín en la capital a las 1:49 pm"
"Tenga en cuenta que cuando comienza el video, estamos viendo la vista interior
cuando la multitud se acerca desde afuera y golpea las ventanas y puertas.
Puede ver que los alborotadores primero rompieron la ventana
con la viga de madera que vio anteriormente y un oficial de policía solitario adentro responde.
Y comienza a rociar al primer hombre que entra, pero se siente abrumado rápidamente.
Quiero que prestes atención al primer grupo de asaltantes cuando irrumpen en el edificio.
El segundo hombre que entra por la ventana lleva un chaleco antibalas táctico completo
y está llevando un bate de béisbol.
Otros llevan escudos antidisturbios ".
"En este video de seguridad, puede ver al oficial Goodman
corriendo para responder a la violación inicial".
"El oficial Goodman pasa al senador Mitt Romney
y le indica que se dé la vuelta para ponerse a salvo".
"Cuando los alborotadores llegaron a lo alto de las escaleras,
estaban a menos de 30 metros de donde se refugiaba el vicepresidente con su familia".
"Los alborotadores que se ven portando un bate de béisbol
en este video son los mismos que vimos hace unos momentos
abriendo la ventana del primer piso".
"Mientras todo esto sucedía,
el vicepresidente Pence todavía estaba en la habitación cercana a la cámara del Senado,
no fue hasta las 2:26 que fue evacuado a un lugar seguro.
Este siguiente video de seguridad muestra esa evacuación,
sus movimientos son representados por el punto naranja en nuestro modelo
los puntos rojos y azules representan la ubicación donde estaban la multitud y el oficial Goodman
y donde el oficial Goodman sacó a los alborotadores de la Cámara hace unos momentos ".
"Se puede ver al vicepresidente Pence y su familia bajar rápidamente las escaleras.
El vicepresidente se gira brevemente mientras se dirige hacia abajo".
"Mientras Pence estaba siendo evacuado,
los alborotadores
comenzaron a extenderse por todo el Capitolio.
Los que estaban adentro ayudaron a otros alborotadores
a entrar por las puertas en varios lugares alrededor de este edificio.
Y la multitud estaba buscando al vicepresidente Pence debido a su patriotismo,
porque el vicepresidente se había negado a hacer lo que el presidente exigió y anular los resultados de las elecciones.
Durante el asalto al Capitolio,
los extremistas se coordinaron en línea y discutieron cómo podían perseguir al vicepresidente.
Los periodistas en el Capitolio informaron que escucharon a los alborotadores decir
que estaban buscando a Pence para ejecutarlo".